problema número 36 de esta figura del
segmento pq cuál es el punto al doble de
lejos de p que de q bueno el punto está
en el segmento que tanto tenemos que
recorrer para ir de aqu
veamos de aquí a cam x se incrementa en
3 123 así que en x avanzamos 3 puntos y
para llegar aquí vamos a avanzar si este
es el punto 3 2 1 2 3 para llegar aquí
aquí también avanzamos en jet 3 si
queremos seguir dos tercios del camino
pues qué tal si incrementamos x en 2 x
lo incrementamos en 2
y también lo incrementamos en dos así
que sería aquí 12 este es el punto que
nos piden y se encuentra en la
coordenada 21 2,1 que es nuestra opción
b veamos el siguiente problema si el
entero positivo n es divisible entre 5 y
7 n debería ser divisible por cuál de
los siguientes esto significa que
tenemos una constante c multiplicada por
5 y por 7 una constante c multiplicada
por cinco y por 7 esto también lo puede
expresar como 7 por 5 35 por ser la
opción 1 no puede ser pues 35 no es
divisible entre 12 la opción 2 pues sí
si va a ser divisible entre 35 aquí lo
estoy viendo la opción 3
35 no va a ser divisible entre 70 así
que la respuesta a nuestra pregunta es
el enunciado 2
que es nuestra opción c veamos el
siguiente problema problema número 38 si
4 es la solución a la ecuación x
cuadrada más 3 x más k igual a 10 k es
una constante cuál va a ser la otra
solución
esta es una ecuación cuadrática vamos a
dejar esto en términos de la ecuación
cuadrática y vamos a restar 10 en ambos
lados de la ecuación me va a quedar x al
cuadrado más 3 x
cam
unos 10 igual a 0
ahora si no tenemos en el formato que
queremos y nos dicen que 4 es una
solución
así que si yo tengo esto x menos 4
x no conozco cuál sea la solución le voy
a poner más b
es igual a cero
y dije que 4 es una solución entonces
porque escribí aquí en menos 4 bueno
pues para que esto sea 0 esta parte
tiene que ser cero o esta parte tiene
que ser cero y para que esta parte sea
cero aquí x tiene que tener el valor de
44 menos 40 por eso es que puse que esté
menos 4 entonces x menos 4 para que sea
igual a 0 x debe ser igual a 4 y es la
solución que nos da ahora encontremos el
valor de b multiplicamos esto estoy acá
vamos a desarrollarlo para ver cómo se
para ver las coincidencias con los
términos ok
x x x x cuadrado menos 4 x
x
- 4 x + b es igual a menos 4 b y eso es
igual a cero
ok vamos a agrupar los términos x
cuadrada puedo poner estados este 2 no
me salió bien pero ahí está
se reagrupó esto ve - 4 x x menos 4 b y
bueno vamos a ver qué coincidencias
tenemos aquí tenemos que término que
multiplica x este 3 debe ser igual a
esto de aquí vamos a ver entonces b
menos 4 debe ser igual a 3 sumó 4 en
ambos lados de la ecuación y me quedaba
igual a 437 ok aquí ya tengo b el que el
que me interesa de este valor lo
sustituyó aquí y me da cero es una
solución de esta ecuación pero lo que me
preguntan es la otra solución con
respecto a x qué valor debería tener x
aquí bueno si x + 7 es igual a 0
x para que esto se cumpla deberá ser
igual a menos 7 esta es la solución a lo
que me están preguntando y esta es la
opción
siguiente problema número 39 x es igual
a menos 3 cuál es el valor de menos 3x
cuadrada aquí quizás quieren probar
nuestra habilidad para resolver
operaciones con potencias vamos a
resolverlo vamos a poner el menos 3 en
el lugar de la x menos 3 por x que es
menos 3
al cuadrado esto es igual a menos 3 x 3
x 39 o menos 3 x menos 39
9 x menos 3 es igual a menos 27
este es nuestro resultado y es la opción
a veamos el siguiente problema el número
40 muy bien nos dan esto y nos piden el
resultado nos preguntan esto a que es
igual
esto lo puedo expresar como 29 al
cuadrado entre 29 más 29 entre 29 así
que estoy expresando así esta suma de
fracciones esto es igual a 29 al
cuadrado entre 29 se me va a este
cuadrado con esto y me queda 29 más 29
29 pues es un 29 más o no esto es igual
a 30 que es mi opción y opción
ok pasemos al último problema de este
vídeo si x es igual a uno menos tres t
es igual a 2 t menos uno para que el
valor de t nos da x igual de bueno
tenemos que igualar
ambas ecuaciones así que podemos
escribir esto como este valor de x o
esta ecuación de x es igual a uno menos
tres t que debe ser igual a la ecuación
de que es 2 - 1 igualados
- 1 ok vamos a sumar 3 t en ambos lados
de esta ecuación y me queda 1 igual a
tres temas 23 igual a 5 t menos 1 esto
sumamos 1 en ambos lados de la ecuación
me queda uno más unos 2 igual a 5 t
y aquí te va a ser igual a 2 entre 52
entre 5 dividimos ambos lados de esta
ecuación entre 5 que es igual a 2 puntos
y esa es la solución que nos pide no nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo